I have a new book out a path appears
which is essentially about how to make a
difference and it addresses all those
people who have this yearning to have an
impact on the world to find a measure of
fulfillment but don't really know how to
go about that and in working on the book
my wife and partner in this effort
Sheryl WuDunn one of the things we
looked at is the kind of connections
that link us to a cause that make us
want to give that we coz want to
participate in something you know this
arose for me this research arose when I
was writing for my column for The New
York Times about Darfur back in 2004 and
I was going to villages that had been
burned out talking to people who were
survivors of massacres and it was
frustrating to me that I couldn't get
people to pay more attention to this and
meanwhile at that very same time here in
New York City there was a red-tailed
hawk called Pale Male that had been
kicked out of its nest off Central Park
and New York was all up in arms about
this homeless Hawk and I thought how is
it that I can generate as much passion
about hundreds of thousands of people
being slaughtered as people feel for
this hawk that led me to this area of
research particularly by a guy called
Paul slovic
and it turns out that our engagement
with a cause it's not about numbers it's
not about classes of victims it's really
about two things it's first of all it's
emotional and it's with individuals that
we have evolved we were hardwired to
feel a certain amount of empathy and a
connection but with one other person
whom we see whom we can relate to not
with a hundred thousand people half a
world away the other thing is that we
want to feel like we're having an impact
so we want some kind of a positive art
we want to see a difference being made
and so when aid organizations talk about
five million people at risk and make it
sound terribly depressing they're
precisely hitting the buttons that turn
people off one of the things that really
struck me was there been experiments
that ask people to do
ooh some math equation solve some math
problems first and it turns out that if
you do that if you exercise the more
rational parts of your brain then you're
less empathetic you're less likely to
contribute those of us who care about
these issues we need to figure out how
to do a better job a storytelling about
individuals and showing that there is a
possibility of hope some of the research
about our preference for helping
individuals over classes of people comes
from experiments where people were asked
to contribute in some cases to this
child one that was used was Rokia a girl
from West Africa versus a large group of
people millions people suffering
malnutrition in Africa and of course
everybody wanted to contribute to Rokia
to that girl they wanted to help that
girl they didn't really care about
millions of people being malnourished
but what was striking is that you know
even though we I think intellectually
know that you know one death is a
tragedy and a million deaths is this is
a statistic that at the point at which
we begin to be numbed is when that
number when N equals two the moment you
added not just Rokia but had a boy next
to her and said you can help these two
hungry kids then people were less likely
to contribute than if it was just Rokia
likewise people are less willing to
contribute to a fund to save kids from
cancer if there is if the same amount of
money is gonna save not one life but
eight lives it really is this bias to
help an individual so we have to figure
out I mean obviously the needs are vast
and so we have to figure out how to open
these lines of communications and move
people at an emotional level to help an
individual but then use that empathy
then to broaden and to serve so many
other people who need help
you